why did they serve sloppy joe at
hospitals so i have a pop machine ready
and I don't understand you know it's
it's you know papa coca-cola machine
it's a great question why don't you go
to the hospital hey I did I did a
three-year residency yeah board
certified in family practice just like
any other physician and you know you go
to a hospital you think some of your
sick and you want to get healthy and a
person's laying there in the hospital
bed again week or awakened every hour
okay so then you know it's been proven
the highest potential of healing is when
you sleep yeah you have to sleep okay so
okay you got these sick patients yeah
it's justified in some cases you have to
wake them up for certain conditions but
for the most part you can let them heal
but then you go down into the lunchroom
in the cafeteria and this servant junk
pizza GMO foods you know sugars tons and
tons of sugars okay and you see what the
visit the patients are getting and their
meals and it's sickening because in my
opinion food in the United States
especially is one of the major causes of
disease and so it's important for me to
educate my patients on nutrition and and
you've had our best buddy jim marlowe on
the show and he frequently sees our
patients and you've just spoken with dr.
Garcia as well so he's a big part of our
diagnostic and and and whole therapeutic
regimen in the office because food is
crucial what you put in your body is
going to either help you get healthier
and keep you healthier it's going to
make you sick and we have so many
problems with digestive diseases I mean
little kids little children okay who if
the mothers don't breastfed in the
newborn and they did drinking this GMO
soy based formulas and it's it's not
healthy form at all so fifty percent of
the battle or more if I get patients
nutrition straightened down it makes my
job so much easier do you do do doctors
learn about nutrition you get did you
guys learn about nutrition and ports of
nutrition in in medical school not
solely not
the closest we get to nutrition in
medical school I don't know about now as
I've been out there for 25 years but as
far as I know because I get students to
come through my office all the time no
one's getting educated on nutrition and
if they do it's about counting calories
yeah and it's about like diabetics if
you if you go see someone who supposedly
specializes in treating diabetics
nutritionally they're going to put them
all on the same diet and you can't do
that the closer we get the nutrition in
medical school is what they call
parenteral nutrition and if there's some
ones in the intensive care unit and they
can't eat they're on a respirator they
have to feed you through a tube and
basically they tell you all the
different nutrients you have to put in
there that's the closest we're getting
okay and in fact nutrition should be the
number one course in medical school it
should be where we start now we have to
learn the whole system's approach
cardiology neurology nephrology
endocrinology etc we need to understand
those things to be a physician and for
me it's an integral part of what I do